good morning everyone thanks for being
here we are five minutes before but we
are go to go the room is almost full
um we will present Michael gorkov
um for a talk on engineering data
science with python and snowflake
he's the CTO of data science at
snowflake so give it a
warm welcome thank you
[Applause]
all right thank you very much for having
me uh my name is Michael actually I'm
not a CTO I'm a field CTO at snowflake
so what it means is
um I have a very technical role but
actually uh with a very narrow focus on
data science and machine learning so
afterwards we have a boost here feel
free to come over if you have questions
in detail my plan for today is give you
an overview of what snowflake can offer
in terms of feature Engineering in the
first place and obviously also about
doing data science model training model
inference Etc in Snowflake
but some Basics before usually people
already know what snowflake is are for
those who not know what snowflake is
what it does very quickly
some history to 14 we started going out
of stealth mode basically our idea was
going to the cloud separate storage and
compute all that stuff that probably a
lot of other vendors today also explain
to you so we skip over that four years
in time 2018 we were talking about
connecting the world of data we had a
lot of customers already on the
snowflake platform all of them are
interested in Sharing data but not only
data but also functionality in Snowflake
and now and this is where my talk is
about today we are talking about 2022
last year we announced something called
programmable data and really the idea is
to not only have data warehousing and
snowflake SQL based Solutions but also
give you the possibility to program your
own apps to do data science and machine
learning modeling all that stuff and of
course also with Frameworks you're
familiar with one of it is of course
Python and we're talking about second
loan XT boost tensorflow Pi torch Etc
all that inside of snowflakes so that
you do not have to extract data for
example from Snowflake to other
Solutions you don't have to manage these
other Solutions all baked in into the
platform now
for those of you who also know streamlit
for example something which we acquired
last year open source framework to
develop applications in Python all that
is also being integrated into snowflake
so we are really trying to give you the
opportunity and stuff like to do more
than just
let's call it classical standard data
warehousing with SQL and how to do that
I will give you an explanation today
um but also some words about why it
makes sense because snowflake is not
only a data science solution it is now a
data platform so probably a lot of your
team members a lot of other departments
are already working on snowflake if
you're a snowflake customer so maybe a
lot of interesting data you want to use
for your data science projects is
already in Snowflake
of course we also talk about reporting
stuff your predictions from your
beautiful models will end up in these
dashboards so probably you also want to
do the data science where your data
already is this exactly what Nova can do
today we are of course focusing today on
this data science and machine learning
part but you can imagine that there are
a lot of other stuffs already happening
on snowflake
what is very important is as we're
working all on the same platform of
course scalability and workload
isolation you can imagine you as a data
scientist you have very high compute
demands probably on tasks which require
a lot of data but there's also the
manager who wants to have his dashboard
there's also some regular processes
running so obviously we want to separate
between them this is what we are doing
in Snowflake with our virtual Warehouse
concept
and also we want to scale depending on
how much compute power you actually need
because provisioning compute power and
the cloud is costly so we always try to
match exactly the demand of the compute
and later on when we dive into a small
demo of all about this uh you will also
see how easy it is to actually do that
in Snowflake also for the data science
workloads
long story short
um
scaling in the cloud is very important
because a candidates the following
here's just an example which Wales
concept works with t-shirt sizes X small
small medium and so on every time we
double the compute and what you can see
here is you can use an S Warehouse doing
some work you can also use an M
Warehouse double the compute power and
achieve the same amount of work at the
same time
or you can use 2m warehouses and achieve
the same amount of work actually half
the time at the end all of them do
exactly the same stuff but the runtime
is Extreme reduced from this uh very
long part here to a very small one if
you have more compute but they all cost
the same because actually you're only
paying for computer you're using so in
Snowflake later on you will see it in
the demo it makes sense also to play
around with compute use more compute if
you need it use less compute if you
don't need it
it is at the end not more costly
coming to the python product
um probably a lot of people already know
that we have been offering a python
connector for quite some time and what
people did is the following you have a
it's not like with the warehouse you
know it understands SQL and a lot of big
benefits come from that data is already
there it is secured you have some robust
access controls in place and this
government you have probably something
like a row level access policy it is
very scalable and it's already connected
all the dashboard Solutions are already
attached or the data sources are already
attached to the itself like but in the
past people said okay but I cannot work
with price I cannot train the cycle to
learn model in self like so what they
did is they used the python connector
select start from table moved all the
data into a data science workbench
basically in any python engine did all
this stuff there and pushed back the
results
of course this introduces latency and
costs every time we move data it costs
you money and also from a security and
governance perspective as soon as this
data here is leaving snowflake obviously
all the road-based access controls are
gone
we don't know what is happening in this
environment here so there must be
someone who's managing that environment
as well
and obviously when we push back the
results we are again introducing cost
because we have to transfer data again
so what if we said is python not
available
so it's a lot less management effort for
you and actually you as a data scientist
have a very quick access to all the data
you want to have in your data science
related work
how does it work
um actually we introduced something
called snowpark and if you remove the
now it will become spark so it will
already give you an impression where we
are going to it's not spark so please
keep that in mind we're talking about
Snowflake and its own compute engineer
but from a syntax and functionality
perspective it will look very familiar
to everyone who already knows Pi spark
especially when we talk about the python
variant for other people coming from the
Scala world I know there's a surprising
conference but usually people also know
Scala the same is true for uh so far it
also is available in multiple languages
and the very first thing we will see for
data engineering is the client-side
implementation or the data frame API
I already have to say sorry for all the
people working with pandas single node
except if you're going to the dust guys
yes they can distribute it somehow our
data fan API is similar to what the
spark data frame does is already
distributed so you don't have to worry
about Distributing stuff we will
automatically do that under the hood
which makes it very easy to work on
really huge data sets
but this is the client-side part usually
we are talking about data engineering
stuff here when it comes to the server
side
we are talking about something called
user-defined functions or on short user
udfs stop procedures as prox and they
also support different languages as we
are on pycon here I'm talking about the
execution of python code and this is
where you would run your cycle law and
XG boost and so on directly in Snowflake
from
an architectural perspective how does it
look on the left side we have the data
frame API what you are doing is you're
coding and python in a data frame API
but under the hood automatically we are
creating SQL statements which are
executed in our normal SQL engine which
will already give you the idea we don't
have to do any magic here SQL is always
distributed in our case so yes all the
data frame manipulations are already
distributed
but not everything can be translated
into a SQL statement like for example a
cycle learn model there's no way of
translating it to SQL we are not going
to try that I know some database
companies tried it and failed so what we
are doing is we had coding or function
but actually we are serializing the
object and sending the bytecode to a
snowflake and next to the SQL engine
close the attached with the so-called
python secure sandbox so a place an
engine running in our same compute
clusters that is attached to Anaconda
which provides all the beautiful open
source packages which allows you to use
for example the cycle model directly in
Snowflake
what are we trying to do uh when we look
at the past this is what people did you
have some data you are doing your select
star you have data in the pandas data
frame trying to do some Transformations
you push it back to an enriched table
you again have to download your data to
your final table calling a fit on the
cycle learn model and then at the very
end you have your predictions and push
that back every time here we are
introducing cost latency security issues
so instead what we're trying to do is
come to a solution like this we only
have pointers to data which basically is
our data frame API so we are not
physically moving data we are physically
moving the logic
and at the very end we can also push all
the heavy lifting of for example so I
could learn into the platform where you
already have your data so we are again
only moving
um
python Logic No data from a distribution
process I mean we have already seen we
are creating SQL queries if you are
using the data frame API so it should
give you an idea that SQL is already
distributed more interesting is the part
about user-defined functions and
um also what we call store procedures
user different table functions for
user-defined functions it is very simple
we have a data frame
we have rows on the data frame and what
we are doing is our row level
distribution so each row gets to a
different compute node we apply our
function to it and at the very end we
assemble all these rows together to
resulting data frame
it is a scalar function so one row in
one result out
very simple
um for python we have a special case
which is called vectorized functions or
pandas user-defined functions what we're
doing here is exactly the same but we
are working in batches of data so
instead of having row by row
Transformations for example in cycle
learn predict is optimized to work on
batches of data so we are of course
using batches of data but basically the
idea is the same for each row that gets
in we have a Scala reside as an output
in this case our prediction
there is a way to use also user-defined
table functions for example if you want
to distribute model training I'm not
talking about Distributing a single
model but for example if you're doing a
grid search or a random search you train
a lot of models in parallel and at the
very end you combine all of these models
and find out which one was the best
configuration and you could do exactly
the same and snowflake you have a
virtual Warehouse that has a lot of
compute nodes each node can train a
separate model at the end we compare all
these models and find out which one was
the best or another idea
and imagine you have different stores
and you want to calculate or train a
model for each store you could
distribute your workload across all the
nodes and for each node you're training
a model for each store
if you have different configurations
this is usually usually the parameter
tuning part user-defined table functions
are also very handy to use
with that said
I would jump to a quick demo to give you
an overview of how Snowflake and
snowpack looks like and I can already
tell you if you're interested in running
exactly the same stuff I have a deeper
dive into the code I will also share a
GitHub repository with all the codes
attached you can create this free
snowflake trial account takes less than
two minutes and run all that code on
your own
but now let's get started
um
with actually this one and we are
clearing the output I am using maybe
is that large enough okay
awesome
um so I'm using visual studio code as a
developer environment here but basically
a snow product itself
is something it's just another python
packet you can use whatever ID you want
but I think visual studio code is a very
good one so highly recommend it
especially because on the left side we
have a snowflake plug-in that shows you
all the available objects and snowflake
like for example we see that we have two
tables in our database
when we start working with snowpack we
always have to connect to snowflake I'm
using a very simple approach I'm just
connecting given some credentials in a
Json file but of course they are smarter
and more secure ways of doing that think
about single sign on keypair
authentication Etc
the more important part for us now is we
are always working in a specific context
in Snowflake we have a role attached to
us and this role defines which tablets
can I see which cables can I edit which
functions can I run so all of the
governance and security around your data
is already put into the platform you
don't have to worry about that
and snowflake terms a little Warehouse
as I mentioned at the beginning is our
term for compute power so remember we
are using a compute cluster called
compute warehouse and we are using it
all the time but we will change it in
between I'm not switching between
different clusters
when we want to create a data frame and
on the left side you see we have already
some tables I can just simply reference
at this table and call it a show to have
a look at the data in our case the use
case is very very simple what we are
doing is we have some e-commerce data
unique identifier some features and we
have a spent variable at the end which
is our Target variable today
and first things first difference
between snowpark data frames and pandas
data frames because I know people love
pandas and there's polas coming out
which I'm very interested in uh and by
the way the syntax is very similar to
what you see here as well but the main
difference is of course the data type
one is notebook data frames one is Panda
data frames but the more interesting
part is the distinction between the
memory usage as you can see the snowpack
data frame it will always consist of 48
bytes which is the size of the pointer
to the data
if we load data into pandas data frame
and we can do that with the two Panda
statement we will load it into memory we
are memory Bound Again
and my recommendation is never caught
upon us if you don't need it
scalability
um very interesting part
so
of course we have some metadata around
our data frames so for example here
we have our columns and for each and
every column we know whether it's a
string type a double type and we have
some other types as well and what I
would like to do now is distinguish
between the different columns in my data
set because probably I want to apply
different functions based on the type so
pretty standard stuff that I also can do
in pandas you can do exactly the same
stuff here
and I'm also using a describe comment to
get a first impression of what my data
looks like we usually have one million
rows but you can see here that we have
some missing values so probably before I
start modeling the data I want to do
something around data engineering
feature engineering missing value
imputation here
and now comes the interesting part we
have one million rows which is obviously
not a lot of data so hence I'm using the
smallest compute size available in
Snowflake and by the way I'm also
turning off any caching so it's really
live computation nothing red from the
background
and now we have defined our compute
cluster
and I can iterate through all of my
columns apply a fill in a function to
fill the missing values and we will see
that this roughly takes five to six
seconds
we have now have 1 million count each
column so basically you have imputed all
of the data everything works fine
but what if we have 100 times the data
so I have another data set created that
has 100 million rows and if I would run
the exact same code on that data set on
my current cluster obviously we would
probably wait like 500 seconds which
would be very boring for all of us
so that is the reason why we can
immediately scale up to a 2X large
increasing
or from extra small to 2x large I don't
know eight times the compute power uh so
we have a really huge machine now
attached to us and as you can see it
took less than two seconds to start it
actually it was even less on the server
side and I run exactly the same code 100
times the data and as we have more
compute power we would expect usually
something like 10 seconds I think on
this size
hopefully the internet connection is not
broken
all right as we are also getting some
results back sometimes it takes a while
but I think you get the idea so we have
more compute and less than a second can
work on larger data sets especially
regarding the data engineering and
feature engineering part
in this case
um it looked quite easy but what about
the one hot encoding stuff here it is
very important to have all the data
because if you only do that on a subset
of data you don't have all of the
different expressions in your data set
in the future so we have to do that on
the whole data which is very very
difficult if you're using a memory bound
pandas data frame
and here's the way of doing one hard
encoding yourself a small function which
produces a one hot encoding on 100
million rows still we are working on the
2x large cluster
and what you can see here is basically
we have new columns for example for the
gender column we now have gender female
agenda male and we had membership status
column with all the different status
this looks very complicated obviously
you don't want to have uh to rewrite the
logic for one hot encoding yourself so
what you can do instead is using build
in Transformers and I know a lot of
people using cycle to learn to do that
yes you can do a psychic learn and stuff
like as well but it will not be
distributed so instead what we want to
do is offering an API that looks like
scikit-learn but is doing it in a
distributed fashion and this is what we
are doing with snowflake ml I know that
is spark ml as well so hence the name
probably and this is what you can do you
can't just import a one hot encoder from
Snowflake ml pre-processing
and have a Distributive way of doing a
one-hot encoding
instead of the psychic learn one so very
similar chord but it will run a lot
faster on larger data sets and also you
will never receive an out of memory
error because we are not memory bound
when we use the data frame API
this is what I'm showing here is this no
ml stuff it is currently in private
preview and June Summit
2023 for snowflake is starting in Las
Vegas you can imagine this is a good
date where we probably announced some
things going from private preview to
public preview or even going to ga
we have to find our training data set so
now I want to split it and there's
obviously also a splitting function in
the data frame API so now we are
splitting 100 million rows and
afterwards we are persisting
all that stuff
because until now we have never
persisted anything as you have seen this
one is a data frame API that is lazily
executed so only executed when you
request results and is also not
persisting anything except if I have to
or if I call a write function
we now have two data sets train and test
and my big task the data entering part
is done so I want to reduce the cost I
scale back to an extra small
and of course I turn the caching on
again there's no reason to ever turn it
off except if you're doing benchmarking
this is the data engineering part and
there's a lot of examples on the web
which tells you exactly what is possible
with the data frame API but this will
just give you an idea easy to use very
similar to probably a lot of Frameworks
you already know except that we are now
running on a scalable compute engine in
Snowflake
next step we are trying to build a
machine learning model in Snowflake and
our ultimate goal is to have a blob
storage location with some model files
stored which we later on can reference
for inference
so what I'm doing is I am creating two
stages actually I'm calling one of eight
functions because remember when we had a
look at our slide here we are sending
bytecode to snowflake so this bytecode
has to live somewhere hence we are
creating a place on the blob storage for
that
and then I'm training a machine learning
model and maybe we start with a python
code first uh so this is just a very
simple function definition it uses cycle
learn random false regression model in
our case and the code you're seeing in
here should look very familiar to anyone
who already coded in Python basically
you already have that code sitting on
your laptop or in some Cloud instances
already there's definitely no change
required
we are only adding a decorator here at
the very top to tell
um that this is actually a server-side
function so this one make sure we create
a store procedure hence the S proc name
called train random force model it lives
in our function State this is where the
byte code will end up and we'll Define
the dependencies basically what do we
have to provide as dependencies during
execution of this function and as we are
using scikit-learn of course we want to
have cycle to learn droplet for the
pickling part and pandas because we are
loading data into pandas data frame
when we Define this one it takes a short
amount of time because now snowpack
under the hood automatically packages
your function serializes it sends it to
snowflake registers the function and on
the left side when we have a look
at our Explorer here and we are now
working in the enriched ones you will
see that we have a trained random forest
model function available
it also comes a nice part as this one
became another database object anyone in
the organization who is working on the
platform can use your function it is
basically already shared with anyone
calling it is very simple I mean right
now it is just a stored procedure and we
are executing it like a simple python
function with all the inputs what's my
training table features Target Etc yeah
I'm only training on the subset of data
so we don't have to wait that much time
um but this one is now executing your
training job on the server side so
there's no data extraction needed if you
have gdpr relevant data for example in
Snowflake probably you're not allowed to
extract it this way would allow you to
put your training logic to snowflake
work on gdpr related data that is
governed and make sure that you can use
the data science in your organization I
get some some coefficiency back to see
what was happening uh in the model
but more importantly we now have in our
modern State and you file my random
forest.sav and we also see it when we
update here on the left our stages and
have a look at my model State here's my
file
so this one can now be picked up
by snowflake of course but you could
also use any other tool that needs this
pickled file uh to do predictions so you
can also train in Snowflake and maybe
run the inference somewhere else or the
other way around you train in some Auto
Machine learning tool I don't know HML
and have a model file ready put it into
a blob storage and we can pick it up
from there do the interference on top of
it
by the way for anyone who is using ml
flow as a model repository they are
built in Integrations to push the model
deployment into snowflake without you
having to write any of the boilerplate
code
why does it make sense let's have a look
at the model inferencing part so we are
basically getting the file object from
the stage and running the user defined
function which is our scoring function
on fresh data how does it look like very
similar to the training part so I'm
defining a scoring function which
essentially is just calling the predict
functions the cycle learn model with the
data I'm importing
some best practices here first of all we
are using a cache decorator for the load
model function why because when we have
a look at this one here what is
happening is each node will get a
various amount of
partitions of data and if you are not
use a cash decorator it would reload
that model for each and every partition
so we are trying to avoid that only the
first car to that function on each
worker node will load the model or the
um other ones after it will load from
memory which is a lot faster so tip
number one
by the way this is not only two for
snowflake but for a lot of other engines
out there as well cache your model
artifacts in your function cards
and we are defining our user defined
functions so this one is not actually a
local function but it is and we can
execute it quickly this one is a user
defined function and this one is a
special case it's the vectorized or
batched user-defined function
hence the reason why I can't Define a
maximum batch size
very important it is what the name
defines here a maximum so when I say 10K
rows it does not have to be 10K because
under the hoods not like tries to be
very smart and optimizes the batch size
for you up to that amount of rows so if
we find out that it makes more sense to
use on smaller batches because you can
distribute it on more nodes because the
virtual Warehouse is larger we will do
that for you
the maximum here is more to avoid
long-running jobs or timeouts
if we have a look at the type obviously
it's of type user defined function and
not a local python function anymore and
let's start with a small amount of rows
that we want to score and here I'm also
scaling up again I want to distribute my
workload I want to use a lot of compute
nodes doing the same work but just on
different batches of data
so I'm calling my my test table here and
I'm creating a new column called
predicted spend and call my function
with my feature inputs
and afterwards I also persist my
predictions so keep in mind this one is
not only executing this scoring job but
it's also writing all the data in this
case I think it's roughly
when we
when we remove that limit it's really 30
million rows so it's quite a huge table
actually
but let's start with this very small one
10K rows will run probably for a couple
of seconds not that much but more
interestingly if you run it again on a
larger table I'm not sure why this
taking so long so now I increase it 100
times we now had 11 seconds what will
now happen under the hood is we will
spawn more python workers and score more
data in a shorter amount of time so in
this case was even faster and you can
imagine that this one as I increase I
could also increase the compute power
behind it so I don't have long running
jobs so I basically use the compute
power I need given the size of my data
here
last but not least I can of course
evaluate my model have a look at the
predictions um I think do I limit it
somewhere oh yeah I do so we don't have
to wait that much time get the
um
the true and the prediction have a look
at my data it is fake data so hence why
this model is performing quite worse but
I think it should give you an idea you
can
visualize data as well and this is my
last recommendation with that part of
the demo if you want to visualize data
aggregate it before or limit your data
set and afterwards call to pandas
obviously if you want to visualize data
we need data in memory so it's good to
do that but only do that if you really
need it
last but not least
what did we do on the snowflake side
very quickly the snowflake UI
this is what your I don't know database
administrator your SQL people or maybe
you as a user would also see and on the
left side we have a small I can call it
data databases we had a pycon demo we
had different schemas and we were mostly
working in the enriched schema and this
is also a place where you find your
stored procedures user-defined functions
and so on and the nice stuff is even the
UI
what you can do is provide privileges so
right now as I'm the owner of that
function and I have not provided someone
access to it nobody else would be able
to use it but imagine we have a finance
department they should be able to train
or at least score a model maybe not
train
um you could easily just provide access
rights to their role the finance role
and they will be able to incorporate the
functions you have developed in Python
directly in their data pipelines or
maybe your data engineer who has no idea
about python but he is more a SQL guy he
can at least incorporate all your python
developments
how does it look like
um
I can use SQL as well for that so this
is the SQL UI one of the possible uis
where you can develop and I can simply
do a call train with all my inputs
this is exactly what we have seen in the
notebook before and now we are training
a model just in pure SQL this is a
feature important we are getting back
and we now have a new model called 1.2
uh one two three four for the scoring
exactly the same scoring a random first
model function directly in SQL it's a
simple select statement nobody knows
that the price Model is behind it
my face
so really nice way of giving your
non-data science guys access to for
example machine learning stuff
all right how are we doing in time
awesome then I would also talk very
quickly about
snow ml
I had a very short part already in my
demo where we talked about the one hot
encoding by the way this one is private
preview again so not yet available to
you but if you're interested in and
you're a snowflake customer let me know
I can make sure that you can access get
access to that what is our idea behind
it
um we know that a lot of code already
exists a lot of people already use
scikit-learn for their data preparation
for example you see a lot of
scale as Transformers Etc here and we
want to make it easy for you to make
that happen on really huge data sets so
what we are offering is a pre-processing
library called snowml as you have seen
which is distributed multi-node executed
and looks very similar to what you
already have as code just that it is
running on the different compute engine
that is capable of scaling
and the other part is modeling training
machine learning models and right now we
are talking snowflake about a single
node execution what does it mean I
mentioned the distributed case for cycle
to learn perimeter tuning yes we can
train a lot of models in parallel but we
are not Distributing the single model
which is different to what for example
spark and L does
there's a big debate whether you ever
need it to have single models
distributed I'm happy to discuss with
you after the talk but right now this is
not possible in Snowflake but we are
working on it so this is something on
our roadmap to offer right now we have
it on the single note but we have very
simple apis to do that and what I would
do last is give you an idea how this
will look in the future again remember
it is still something which is going in
a private preview so we are switching
back I have another notebook
it is exactly doing the same stuff
um so we are again connecting to snow
flag we're again having some e-commerce
data all that is exactly the same but
here comes the Transformer part and of
course we can work with pipelines
something you know from Psychic learn I
can define a complex pipeline I need
some one-hub encoding in this case I
also do a min max scaling
cycle learn syntax but it's not psychic
learn it is snow park called under the
hood we are calling a fit on our train
data frame and we are transforming our
train data frame with our fitted
Pipeline and as a result you will see
that yes the membership column with
status is basic bronze Etc is actually
working and these are also the scaled
um columns in our data frame
for the training itself it also looks
very similar we have a grid search uh
cross-validation where you can just
provide an estimator
everything is exactly like and cycle to
learn but actually is running on the
server side so this one what it does
under the hood is it will automatically
create the boilerplate code we have seen
in uh
here a store procedure this is what is
created under the hood for you but you
don't have to write it yourself which
makes it even easier I think for people
to make a transition from a single node
execution to snowflake snowpark
execution
and of course afterwards we can again do
our
our evaluation of the model
and have our output here
so as I said currently in private
preview we are planning to offer that
very soon and to just make it easier for
you to transition from something like
scikit-learn to snowflake
what ads is important
um I have seen that there is some uh
interest around streamly because I think
there's also another session about
streamlit and I want to give you an
impression of what this means in
Snowflake terms in the future because
right now we have created
um a store procedure that is able to
train a model we have a scoring function
we have it available via SQL so probably
a data engineer who can code will be
able to incorporate into Data pipelines
but I will give you one example of what
this might look like in the very near
future and I go into another account for
that where I have it enabled called
streamlit in Snowflake
and remember we had this uh store
procedure where we were able to train a
random Forest
and
how does it look like if we will build
an app on top of it on the left side you
have an Editor to edit streamlit apps
and these streamlab apps are hosted and
executed in Snowflake
so all on the left is basic streamlit
code right it just defines what we are
seeing on the right page as an
application
the interesting part is this one here
and by the way it's using snowpark of
course for all the data engineering
stuff and so on and we are calling our
trained random forest model function in
our application code
so we are utilizing snowflake here for
training a model
one nice thing is we don't have to worry
about credentials because as we are
already connected to Snowflake and we
already have a role attached and we
already have provided credentials we can
just get an active session so nobody has
to play around by
um by sharing credentials or have to
secure credentials or that is
automatically done
and on the left side and maybe click
this one on the right side we have our
application this is what an end user
would see after he's getting the link to
our application and he can Define for
example what table I want to use for my
training I have a Target I have some
features as inputs and I can Define what
the model should do in terms of
parameters do I want to have 10 or do I
want to maybe have like 15 estimators on
how many rows do I want to train tree
depth and so on and we want to have a
new model and it should be saved in a
stage called models and now I click on
submit and on the server side it will
automatically spawn
a job which is training a model and
saves it in a snowflake stage
so really nice and easy way of sharing
your data science work also via UI
applications and you don't have to worry
about where do I host this UI it is
hosted itself like where do I host the
training code it is hosted in Snowflake
and executed
and nothing is really changing because
all of that is working on snowflake
virtual warehouses even hosting this app
right now it is running in the snowflake
virtual Warehouse
so really easy for you to share all
these results
um with other departments for example
and the nice stuff is
um this is coming pretty soon so again I
refer to our Summit in Las Vegas
um so it will be very soon available for
all of our customers right now it is in
private preview so again if you're a
customer if you're interested in trying
that out let me know we can make sure
that it is getting enabled for you very
soon
was that said some recommendations if
you're interested in more information if
you want to have a deeper look at it I
mentioned it uh
there is actually the GitHub repository
for the ones who want to have the link
feel free I think the the slides will be
shared or just scan the QR code it will
link you to the GitHub repository it is
exactly the demo I showed today which is
very high level
but I think it's very good for a first
impression if you want to have more
examples I highly recommend to go on to
Google and
Google snowflake Quick Start
and the very first non-sponsored link is
the it's not a quick starts page
yes we are paying some money to Google
for advertising and you can type in snow
park and you see a lot of tutorials and
not only about basic data engineering
and a model training stuff but I think
there was also something like
um
I think computer vision was already in
there if you're interested in feature
stores fee is tagged on integration for
example which also under the hood use
snowpark you will find the tutorial here
or just go on medium.com search for
snowpike there's a ton of interesting
blog articles
that explain basically the ald
e out of the possible like I don't know
natural language process in computer
vision stuff uh streaming capabilities
Etc all what you can do with snow park
today
and with that said uh I am finished
thank you very much for the intention
and open for any questions you have
thank you Michael uh yeah we have time
for questions
um anyone in the room
um
why did you build your own spot like
language and not for you Spark
um
actually you are running on a completely
different compute engine so it's not
running spark and under though it's
running virtual warehouses so we needed
a different API on top of that
okay but we're not at work if you are
using spy from the beginning like other
performances difference like fundamental
differences
because from what we saw it does
basically the same thing as Park
um not exactly
um I think you probably have seen it but
it takes less than a second to change
compute okay so it's faster than Spark
um yes because we are talking about the
shared architecture here so all the
compute
is basically a very huge poll about
around other stuff like customers so
yes you can more or less achieve the
same as work if you manage your own hot
pool but in Snowflake I mean it's
software as a service
shared architecture so
there's a big difference in what is
happening technically under the hood
hence we needed
um something like snow park and don't
work is not only sparked but as you have
seen we also include something like the
transformer stuff there will be a model
registry integration very soon with snow
park so it's definitely not only
spark like framework but there will be
our developer framework around snowflake
in total
um and especially when it comes to
anything related to python
thank you very much
uh thanks a lot for your talk it was
very interesting and insightful I have
one question regarding the python
sandbox runtime how can you configure it
like for example can you specify
different python versions uh what about
CPU and memory because I can imagine a
case where you run into out of memory
issues which is very common with um with
python and also when you use like um
storing and loading those models it uses
joblib and unloaded pickle and between
different python versions those pickling
processes they are not compatible how do
you solve this yeah very good question
uh let's start with the first one maybe
can I run different python versions the
honest question at the honest answer
right now is not yet we are now talking
about 3.8 uh 3.9 should come in the next
couple of weeks I think 310 is probably
around Summit in in June
and you will specify the version you are
using during the definition of your
store procedure as you have seen I
specified the dependencies like Cyclone
1.2 I think I was using you can also
specify the exact python version you
want to use and in the future whenever
you execute that function we will never
change the version so if you want to
have a newer version you would for
example redefine that function with
different dependencies so that is I
think one way how we would avoid
loading a different model with a
different python version
regarding the CPU memory stuff I mean
the snowflake's perspective was always
to make it very easy so the end was the
reason why we created this extra small
small medium sized compute clusters and
yes there are customers asking for like
Hey how do I Define how much memory do I
have we don't have that because we still
want to make it easy but what we do have
is so-called snowpack optimized
warehouses so if you go into the
snowflake UI and you are an admin and
you are allowed to create a virtual
Warehouse what you can do is once you
have at least medium sized one you can
choose a warehouse type to snowpark
optimize and I think
here's also the explanation what it does
16 times the memory we're roughly
talking about 230 240 gigabytes of
memory and of course also more caching
so if you have larger artifacts like
deep learning models for example this
would be the way to go
one thing to keep in mind when I
activate the software optimized here the
credit price will be 1.5 times the one
of the standard warehouse
foreign
for the talk
um I have mainly two questions first one
uh any plan to move also towards nosql
databases underneath
um or is there maybe already any plan
right now
no SQL data no secret and it's no secret
either I was like do we have a new
product uh
um honestly I don't know
um
not that I'm aware of okay so right now
only SQL
yeah my question would be more like what
are you interested in when using nosql
um simply the background of or the
advantages of using nosql is just
dumping data coming from different
sources easily um into the database
without having any type of schemas and
taking care of the schemas afterwards
um but that's exactly what you can do
and stuff like today we have a data type
called variant which basically can
receive whatever data you want and then
afterwards you can Define the structure
to work on top of it we also are working
on something called schema Evolution for
example so over time probably a schema
changes we were automatically detect it
and adapt your schemas so this is
definitely something you would do today
already in Snowflake perfect sounds like
something I look into and then second
question
um have you any figures about the
overhead of the client server
um computation that you do
um oh um today I use the local Jupiter
notebook to do all that stuff but when
you run this in production of course you
wouldn't not schedule local notebooks
not even I mean I think notebooks are
terrible way of putting things into
production so usually you have some
Python scripts and you want to execute
them and one way of doing that in
Snowflake is snowflake store procedure
so basically my whole notebook code I
have I would just put an install
procedure and it will be executed on the
server side you can schedule it on the
server side so this was really just for
demonstration purposes and once it is
executed on the server side there is no
computation over it even here right now
all the logic was pushed to the
snowflake so the training was not
executed locally and especially all the
data frame stuff is this at the end just
generating SQL queries that are executed
on the snowflake side only retrieving
results collect show to Partners Etc
this is where you would download data
from Snowflake hence I always use like a
limit statement to only collect 10 rows
or show statement will automatically
only collect 10 rows so it is really
very small of it yeah
okay thanks a lot
we have time for one more who was first
so quick question what's the cost
structure for the streamlit app
uh it is exactly the same pricing for
all of the stuff you have seen today so
in some Flex terms when you create a
warehouse you will see these credits
here there's our way of charging and a
streamlit app when it runs for one hour
and it runs on an Xbox One it will be
one credit if you run a training job for
one hour it will be one credit so
whatever you do it's only the runtime of
the virtual Warehouse the compute you're
paying for
so
um so it's warning basically while I'm
providing it for us as it's running so
if I just want to make it available to
my customer for the whole month I'm
paying for a whole month or just by
accessing it uh so your streamlit app
should probably not run 24 7. but we
will automatically when someone is
accessing this new lab
provide compute when he closes the
browser I think I don't have it open
anymore the streamlit app will
automatically go in like sleep mode
and when I have to provide more inputs I
would activate it again so you're only
paying for what you're using for
otherwise Cloud will always be very
expensive if you're running jobs 24 7.
okay thank you
um thanks for the talk just a quick
question regarding again the python box
so is it possible to integrate with
um
non-public repository so if you have an
internal repository where you create
packages can you use them as well or is
it limited to Piper so
it's not using Pi Pi it's using Anaconda
we partner with them you are limited to
what this snowflake Channel we have a
dedicated snowflake Channel with
Anaconda is providing but what you can
do is provide any code that is pure
pricing
the only limitation is if you have
non-native dependencies like for example
numpy obviously yes you have a python
interface but it's running in CC plus
plus other languages for security
reasons we are not executing these
non-native dependencies uh but if it is
a pure python Library some custom model
you have developed uh you can just bring
it in as an external dependency we will
execute it
okay thanks
and by the way one last comment we're
going to let if you are also having the
need for external access like I don't
know web scraping calling web apis right
now it's also limited to security
reasons we don't want real data going
into a pricer function and by accident
going to the internet because you were
not careful enough to make sure that
it's going to the wrong to the right
direction but very soon we will
introduce something called external
access where you can provide a white
list of secure endpoints I don't know
your Google image recognition API and
you want to call that you would Define
it in the white list beforehand so that
you make sure you only provide access to
this endpoint and then you can also use
a python UDF to call these endpoints for
example
thank you very much for the questions
and Michael again for your talk that's
[Applause]
um